when i looked at the studies on ketamine
it appeared that um you know this was
like incredibly efficacious uh very few
contraindications to other medicines and
uh and also too it seems to you know
work very very quickly which is which
which is great um so because of that you
know i started prescribing for for my
patients um a lot of the studies on
ketamine will be with say like iv
infusions so the way that i do it i
actually do it um with with capsules
orally
so it's a very very low low dose so you
know with with ketamine i find like
in the classical sense i mean this is
changing now but a lot of people sort of
use it
as almost like a macro dose of like a
psychedelic where like they'll like do
an injection and then they'll sort of
you know kind of get the benefits of
that and then hope that it'll you know
last a long time and for some people you
know they they may just be going through
a difficult period and maybe they just
need that one blast to kind of rip them
out of it and they can kind of you know
get back to normal functioning um but
for other people you know unfortunately
that that just doesn't always always
happen so having like a small amount
that's just like continuous is what i do
so some of my patients will take it uh
once a week some will take it you know
last once a month but i have other
patients that take it you know two or
three times a week just just a low dose
and that seems to be you know incredibly
efficacious overall for for treating
depression and also uh for treating
chronic pain but i would say more
efficacious for um
for depression and mental health and for
chronic pain
interesting
okay
and just one more thing on that too i
know i mentioned it briefly but like
ssri selective serotonin we have taken
inhibitors like classically like people
will say you know this is going to take
four to six weeks to work might take
three to six months that kind of thing
um which can be very very frustrating
especially if someone you know is like
suicidal you know they need something
right away um you know the ketamine like
i said you know it works generally
within 24 hours or less people generally
tend to notice like a difference in
their overall demeanor
um what neurotransmitters does ketamine
work on it's not because they use it as
a
yeah surgical tranquilizer
yeah so that's a it's a good question so
it's an nda receptor antagonist so it
has a very very different mechanism of
action than um than the other medicines
and also too like ketamine often gets uh
grouped as a psychedelic but it
technically it's not a psychedelic now
the reason that it does get groups of
psychedelic is because you know you do
get quite dissociated um it is quite
psychoactive and it does produce you
know a lot of similar beneficial effects
of psychedelics and in terms of
improving overall mental health but you
know it it is actually a a psychedelic
um i'm sorry a uh yeah a uh a anesthetic
sorry so that's why um you know people
do get that very very dissociative um
type of feeling when they use it and
also too it does have a completely
different mechanism of action so all the
um classic psychedelics like psilocybin
like they would act on the 5 hd2a
receptor so ketamine does something
that's you know completely different
wow
and so does that end up because it works
on nmda versus so it doesn't work on
gaba or serotonin
right
like like indirectly it does but but it
doesn't work specifically on those
receptors
so does that make it less likely to be
dependency forming or for sure
i mean absolutely i mean i you know like
a cane you know you can you still can
develop a dependence on academy but it's
very very uh it's it's it's
i don't have any patients that have
become dependent on it but put it that
way i've been doing it for you know
three years now and people say that when
they stop taking it you know they they
don't get the benefit of the medicine
anymore but they certainly don't feel
like they need ketamine or like or they
need it right now or that they feel
addicted or dependent on it
wow i've never heard of it being taken
by capsule i've just heard about these
like high-dose infusions that cause
hallucinations really for a lot of
people that's interesting i mean it's
it's kind of like you know i guess you
could uh look at the way that i
prescribe ketamine as the way that um
you know people do say micro dosing with
psilocybin so you know it's not in your
best interest to you know take uh you
know five grams you know the terence
mckenna heroic dose of five grams more
of psilocybin and you know um and and
think that everything is just going to
be you know okay i mean you may have a
wonderful experience but you know you
you may not right but for um micro
dosing you know a lot of people do tend
to do pretty good with that not
everybody but a lot of people do so for
ketamine you know some people you know
may respond very well to that you know
big blast infusion of ketamine but some
people may respond to just a low dose of
ketamine you know a couple times a week
almost as like a microdose
that sounds a lot safer i know a few
people who had absolutely horrifying
experiences with high dose ketamine um
so that sounds like a good idea just to
even test out
yeah i think so too i think so too and i
mean my patients have done you know
really really well with it and um you
know it's it's a very safe medicine when
you take it uh you know appropriately
and safely when you use the right dose
um and you know i hope that you know it
becomes a little bit more mainstream in
the future
yeah why do you think it's not that's
really interesting because i can see how
like i know i had ketamine once when i
had um
my hip injected
um when i was a kid they gave an
infusion of ketamine and i was still
awake but i was like calm and i can
remember feeling what it was like and
being like okay
i'm calm right so i can see how micro
dosing that could make somebody calmer
why wouldn't that be more of a
mainstream treatment given the fact that
it doesn't work on neurotransmitters
that are going to cause
severe addiction com you know compared
to say gaba or serotonin why isn't it
more mainstream well that's a really
good question i mean on my first thought
on that is that you know i think most of
the research on ketamine has come out in
the last 10 or 12 years i don't think
there was as much research on it done
done before
um
so that'll be you know that the main
reason why some people just i think are
very uncomfortable with prescribing
something that is a little bit
psychoactive and you do have to be
careful about um you know and when i say
psychoactive to me i know that you know
ssris and it's always psychological so
like but psychoactive and like
dissociative you know so some people are
just sort of like apprehensive about
using that and some people just don't
want you know that kind of big change
overall in their and their in their
behavior and their in their brain you
know when they're using a medicine um
but you know
i think that it will change in in the
future and there is a uh a product now
in in the states called escamine that's
been approved that's the intranasal um
i've heard of that yeah yeah yeah so so
i do think that it is becoming more and
more popular now i just think that we
need probably more um physicians to
become comfortable and howling to use it
and that i think more physicians need to
be comfortable in using it as say like a
capsule or as like a micro dose kind of
thing like um like i'm doing as opposed
to like you know this can only be used
um with a big blast of it as in iv where
you need
nurses and and uh you know you need
people to watch your vitals and all that
like you don't need that when you're
doing a very low dose